and first up he represents illinois 16th
congressional district wow when he's on
our show he's the founder of the country
first pack please welcome
adam kinzinger adam
how are you sir i'm good how are you
thank you for doing this show i think uh
we all know why you're here you are one
of 10
republicans in the house who voted to
impeach so
it's interesting the way our country
works now we're so tribal
i bet you right now have a lot of new
friends and a lot of new enemies
is that true yeah that is true and
you know it's uh you're right i think
we're picking tribes it's it's kind of
like
the inability to make independent
decisions now and so when you're one of
10 people that vote to impeach the
president and you cross him
uh you get a lot of the base mad but you
also see a lot of people that understand
you know we need a republican party that
maybe isn't crazy and can actually
be a a productive member of a government
that has basically two parties
right
when was the last time you think we had
that
no really look it's been a while i think
definitely since uh since president
trump we haven't
because but i think it's even really
honestly since i've been in politics
this is my 11th year and if you think
about it
we have learned and i can only speak you
know as a republican looking at the
republicans is
we've learned that you can get elected
on a steady diet of fear and so every
fundraising email
is send me five bucks to make sure that
you know
nancy pelosi doesn't destroy your family
and it's everything is this diet of fear
and eventually there's no wonder there's
real damage done to democracy so that's
what my whole idea of country first is
all about is
a putting the country first before the
party but b
having a little bit of optimism about
the future of the greatest country in
the world that knows no limits except
our own imagination
so wow
i can't get my solder turned on so i'm
not going to argue with you there
i think we have a few more limits than
that but anyway you mentioned
family i know certain members of your
own family
did they not claim that you were now
possessed by the devil
yeah so i was i was over at my uh
parents house and
and out of nowhere i got a registered
letter to my parents house
that same day and it i read it and it
was just i mean two
handwritten pages really tiny letters
really angry a lot of caps
just saying i'm now in the devil's army
because i dared turned against
president trump and actually i'll tell
you i got a second certified letter
reiterating that by the way about two
weeks ago
but the thing about that is i'm actually
happy i got it because it really woke me
up to the
to the level of brainwashing in some
people and the
the understanding they truly believe
that they are fighting against the
forces of
evil just because you know the person
that they
thought was the second coming basically
turned out to lose
do you believe there is such a thing as
a devil
i do yeah absolutely i do and i think
but i think when you look well
you know i was in okay then you talk
about brainwashing and
you know i mean if you believe that
there's such a thing as a devil to begin
with
aren't we halfway to nonsense right
there
well it's what you believe but listen
i'll tell you i was sitting there on
insurrection day
and i've got to tell you i felt
literally like pure evil coming into the
capitol and i and i've talked to many of
the officers
including officer fanon who was a guy
that was drugged down the stairs and
told kill him with his own gun
and he's like man i've never seen people
like that so i don't care
you know if you call it evil or not it
was something that was
crazing these people to believe that if
you go into the capital and destroy it
you're somehow
doing a service for your country so i
know you you feel i'm i'm glad you do
and i wish you the best with this
project that you can reclaim
the republican party but
i do i'm looking at the numbers
congressman and they're not
you would need a swing of about 40
points i mean
trump wants to start his own party 33
percent of republicans are
down with that right away another 37
percent
say probably maybe so only 30
are are with republican classic
for you to reclaim the party
again i think you would need a swing of
about 40 percentage points how can you
really accomplish that
so it is herculean and the thing i've
looked at it is
is that there has been no counter voice
in the party
to donald trump everybody's been scared
and that's where i've finally decided
just to be
extremely bold about it is to say people
need to hear
the other side of this they need to
remember that there is a
a really rich history of the republican
party we can be better and
and so i basically just did a video put
it on countryfirst.com with the one by
the way
but i did that with the intention of
just saying what i wanted to say
and the reaction was i mean 20 000 you
know email sign ups in 24 hours and what
it showed
it's not just disaffected republicans
it's independents and it's even some
democrats that are like
we just want a sane republican party so
all i can do is put it all in the field
i may fail that's okay i'm at peace with
trying
uh but somebody's got to do something
you're willing to lose your job that i
mean isn't that
that's i i you gotta you say you you've
been in congress 11 years
right i have yeah okay and you served
overseas i mean you've been in worse
places obviously in congress right
okay yeah tell me what is so great about
this job
that people are willing to sell their
souls is it just because you get a staff
you're a celebrity is that it because
these people because let's be honest you
don't need any skills
to do the congress i'm not i'm not you
but i'm just saying it's one of the few
jobs in america where there's no checks
all you have to do is get people to vote
for you you can be the biggest [ __ ] in
the world and i've interviewed some of
them
and you can get all you need is a clip
on tie
and the votes and you're there why why
what is it is that really what it is
they just don't want to give up the job
that gives them a kind of a celebrity
i think it is i think some of it is is
it's just fear
you know it but i think it's also you
spend your whole life trying to get to
congress it's a big deal to get to
congress and then all of a sudden
when you think that's your terminal job
or you're going to go higher
you live in fear of anything you do but
i'll tell you bill what i've constantly
said to people is this
you know we as a as a military guy
myself and i've been to war
is like if we're going to ask young
people to be willing to give their life
for the country
you know how dare we not be willing to
give our career for something that
may not be just like warfare but maybe
you